you know a couple years ago I heard
someone call my mom the n-word
that's Megan Markel speaking candidly
about her own experience with racism in
a 2012 campaign that's resurfaced in the
wake of George Floyd's death it's just
hit me in a really strong way at the
time the former suit star participated
in the I won't stand for campaign as
part of the charity erased the hate in
the video she wears a shirt reading I
won't stand for racism and opens up
about being biracial I'm biracial most
people can't tell what I'm mixed with
and so much of my life has felt like
being a fly on the wall and so some of
the slurs that I've heard the really
offensive jokes or the names it's just
hit me in a really strong way Megan also
shared one particularly painful
experience with her mom Doria Ragland
you know a couple years ago I heard
someone call my mom the n-word so I
think for me beyond being personally
affected by racism just to see the the
landscape of what our country is like
right now certainly the world and to
want things to be better
Megan added that the way people are
treated is often based on how they look
certain people don't look at me and see
me as a black woman or a biracial woman
they treat me differently I think than
they would if they knew what I was mixed
with Megan who recently relocated to her
hometown of Los Angeles with her husband
Prince Harry and their one-year-old son
Archie said leaving LA was like leaving
this bubble where she didn't experience
much closed mindedness
it just really opened my eyes to a
mentality that still exists you know I
thought that that was really isolated to
those days that we were past and sadly
they're not back in 2016 Prince Harry
issued a rare public statement
addressing his concerns of racism
criticizing the press for subjecting his
then-girlfriend to a wave of abuse and
harassment Megan also spoke out about
the abuse during the couple's engagement
interview you know it's
it's a shame that that is the climate in
this world to focus that much on that or
that that would be discriminatory in
that sense but I think you know the end
of the day I'm really just proud of Who
I am and where I come from and we have
never put any focus on that we've just
focused on who we are as a couple and in
the throwback charity video megan shares
her hope for a brighter future i am
really proud of my heritage on both
sides I'm really proud of where I've
come from and where I'm going but yeah I
hope that by the time I have children
that people are even more open minded to
how things are changing and that having
a mixed world is what it's all about I
mean certainly it's it makes it a lot
more beautiful and a lot more
interesting
[Music]